woke mind virus how did it start was it
bats was it a yeah escape from a lab I'm
glad that Bill Maher is saying this
stuff but the Applause that he gets on
the right is a little bit overdone and
it's overdone because nobody is ever
stopping to point out the obvious here
okay there's an answer to the question
that Bill Maher asks bill you know you
know what's the origin of the woke my
heart you're the origin not just you but
liberalism it was born
from the liberalism that you still
ascribe to it is a logical extension of
that and this is a point that needs to
be made and the conservatives need to
make rather than simply applauding and
say oh it's so good that someone this is
one of the good leftists and the more
that people like Bill Maher can pretend
that wokeness is completely divorced
from the leftism that he ascribes to and
and promotes the more that he's able to
pretend that the the worse it is